[Music]
of the roughly 7,000 languages spoken
and signed on earth about 500 of them
are currently at risk of disappearing as
the number of native speakers dwindles
this is the story about one man
dispatching an army of volunteers to
record these languages before it's too
late
my name is Daniel and I'm the co-founder
and director of wiki tones a non-profit
powered by more than a thousand
volunteers around the world working to
preserve promote and pass on every
language to the next generation every
day hundreds of volunteers around the
world are recording videos Pendleton
Justin 1880 Sima
Ascona yahwah Iguala kata a loogey
Aronian i help keep track of all of
these videos as they're submitted so
that they can be reused for educational
and cultural purposes
New York is very important to linguistic
diversity New York is by most statistics
the most linguistically diverse city in
the world there are as many as 800
languages spoken in and around the five
boroughs in many cases it can be easier
for communities to maintain their
languages here than it is to maintain
their languages at home today we're
gonna meet up with wiki tongues
volunteers who are going to be taking us
through different parts of New York so
we're gonna speak on wiki tongues
focuses on recording oral histories
which is a fancy way of saying talking
about yourself and your culture
sometimes people barely talk about their
language at all and they just talk about
their daily job in their language of
course sometimes people talk about the
history of their language in their
culture my name is Elfie Goliad
I will speak our language met upon Amma
Elfie Goliad Vitale read oboe Doughboy -
depalo aru tempat Vitali logic on the
wiki tongues approaches record
everything and classify it later what I
do is make sure that all of that content
gets tracked and archived so it does get
lost and so it can be used for posterity
and in the long term definitive wiki
tons has recorded over four hundred and
thirty-five languages from over 70
countries that number changes every day
there are plenty examples of languages
being brought back from the dead there's
Cornish there's Hebrew there's Tunica
all of these languages had one thing in
common when the last native speaker died
there were materials for the cultural
descendants to bring them back and so
building an open archive of every
language in the world is not just a way
of an
during that people today can promote and
teach their languages to the next
generation it's a way of ensuring that
future generations can revive their
languages even if they go extinct there
are only about a hundred and fifty
speakers of the Ocracoke broke now and
they all live on one end of this barrier
island on the coast of North Carolina
which is basically an enlarged sandbar
within the next 50 years the brogue will
disappear or you'll resign so we're
laughing our water far tonight moonshine
no fish
the dialect on this island is sometimes
referred to as boy toy ters which is
their pronunciation of high tide toyed
on a sinusoid high tide on the sinusoid
in the United States the Ocracoke brogue
is probably the only dialect that is not
identified as being from America
I do would have a lot of people that
think I'm from Australia or or IRA yeah
you can even see sea crabs you know the
first people came here from England and
Ireland Scotland it's just a nice lady
I'm from Mill Creek Oh I am the tenth
generation in my family from Ocracoke
that goes back to the mid sixteen
hundreds the reason this dialect was
perpetuated for a couple of centuries
was because the people were very
isolated they didn't have much contact
with with people from the mainland
Ocracoke is an island that has always
lived around the water daddy
many of the unique items particularly
the vocabulary items are built around
the water and the sand and the weather
we had blowing really hard uses blow is
blown Harding a pop car die die you know
you taking a ride around the island you
just take that little
when we come out here and we is blowing
really hard and we take a big I take a
bad beating then you could say we'd be
mama you also find here lots of terms
for outsiders
y'all are Dame batters this my wife is
from Maryland
we've been married 43 years she's still
a dingbat that's not a bad thing okay
it was basically the ding batters who
change the dialect because so many
people came in even today there are more
off islanders who live here than online
Durr now it's changing within time we're
all going to lose it you know because of
so many people came in it's a part of
Harwich that are brighter
some people think we talk funny I think
that's the way we talk okay it ain't
fair enough but get matter I mean that's
fine you know
[Music]
else kahuna he white are you mean hombre
Hinata Flores tennoji-sensei knows say
cantante yo estoy tratando de preserve
our el idioma k2l Quechua su idioma la
nostra sente Posadas los incas y tambien
no esta Kultura yes idioma ahora esta
perdido en el peru let him take in the
way and I catch a kuhmo I will similarly
the Padres ax
oh the discrimination see Sofia del
Quechua time in stereo propensity is
appreciated in Peru here come and say I
can tell the continuously modernist in
Quechua my yard mental prowess her
Venezuelan escuchar lope and establish
no you had a great run
ain't nothing new
discussing this game instead of saying
Quechua a friend of Michael Jackson's in
there is a kid
[Music]
in a concerned a Michael Jackson why
were you making it so Masumi young
babysitter
if we can't get so you know come
yourself and more propensity and CEO the
apartheid lost colonies new serie
antonella's personas they get connect
appreciation
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the non-poor thought here that that is a
military code of the Choctaw Nation I
can understand it
neither could the Germans
[Music]
our story starts in the Western Front
during World War one the Allies are in
trouble the Germans had tapped their
phone lines and deciphered their codes
as the Allies struggled to find a
solution one captain overheard two of
his native American Choctaw soldiers
speaking their mother tongue and the
captain overheard the two soldiers
speaking their native language they
probably thought they were in really big
trouble that's new Jena Shobha
hi there great-granddaughter one of
those two soldiers and president of the
Choctaw code talkers Association around
this time if I talk to her were caught
speaking the language they were liable
to be sent away to a re-education
program but the captain he had a
different idea if I can't understand
what they're saying
perhaps the Germans won't understand
what they're saying the US military
began transmitting tactical messages in
Choctaw and unsurprisingly the Germans
could not break the code not our
military terms had a direct Choctaw
translation machine gun was little guns
shoot fast ammonition
was arrows and gas bottle was bad air
and due at least in part to the Choctaw
code talkers in their neologisms the war
ended soon thereafter when you look at
how ironic it is for the government to
say you can't speak your language but
yet they used them to help win World War
one
that's pretty amazing to me
[Music]
[Applause]